let's do the rousing welcome to mr. Hank
Williams
Marat Florida roll
when he first came to see me he played
some songs he'd written in offered him a
contract though
easy baby congratulations
yes son mr. Williams he's gonna have
real they're not like it was for me the
brand new recipe drinking like a fish
Matt can you write a little poem of Lord
why don't you write me a poem I might
have them get to know you a little
better there's a lot of speculation
about the hard live set folks embers
away what ma are you go out on the road
and you sleep with a different woman
every night I need you with me
you think you could treat me right in it
I can try business is tough on marriage
marriage is tough all mare's you're
barely even here you're barely even
uh-huh
boy I'm a professional I'm making a mess
of things
everybody has a little darkness in him
now I'm talking about things like anger
sorrow shame mm-hmm I show it to him and
they hear him and they don't have to
take it home country music it's sincere
man saying to say it song he knows I
said